40% of the human race did not survive beyond
its 1st birthday.
The word time is the most commonly used noun
in the English language.
The human heart pumps enough blood in a lifetime
to fill three supertankers.
The dialling code for Russia is 007.
In 2008, a man in Ohio was arrested for having
sex with a picnic table.
The Nazis made it illegal on pain of death
for apes to give the 'Heil Hitler' salute.
In Japan only 2% of adoptions are of children;
98% are adult males aged 25 to 30.
Liechtenstein, the world's 6th-smallest country,
is the world's largest exporter of false teeth.
10% of all the photographs in the world were
taken in the last 12 months.
British spies used to use semen as invisible
ink, but they stopped because it began to
smell when it wasn't fresh.
In the 12th century, the Danish army consisted
of seven men.
The ancient Romans discovered parrots could
speak and taught them to say 'Hail Caesar'.
But when they got bored with this, they took
to eating them instead.